[Música]
y con nuestra segunda invitada el día
vamos a analizar Qué es lo que está
ocurriendo realmente en torno a toda la
polémica de los tanques de guerra
leopard de fabricación alemana que puede
ser Todavía están a la espera de ver si
son enviados por Polonia a Ucrania Por
qué Porque Alemania El fabricante de
estos tanques de guerra tiene que dar
alguna especie de autorización para que
Polonia puede enviarlo sin embargo las
autoridades apolacas han dicho que van a
hacer todo lo necesario para ayudar a
Ucrania esto podría desencadenar en una
atención política entre Alemania y
Polonia pues se lo vamos a preguntar a
nuestra segunda invitada del día Ella es
diana Luna analista internacional
gracias Diana por estar con nosotros en
directo América de Francia 24 Cuál es la
verdadera polémica que hay en torno a
estos tanques de fabricación alemana
leoparta
sí existe toda una polémica de hecho se
le llama ya
el debate de los de los tanques los
tanques de la discordia es un tres dos
aspectos el primero es que los tanques
leopardos son producidos en Alemania
entonces Alemania tiene que dar luz
verde para una posible rexportación de
otros países como Polonia Estonia otros
países del Báltico el segundo aspecto es
clave
existe en la opinión pública todavía un
debate sobre evitar a toda Costa
cualquier posible escalada militar y el
envío de estos tanques es visto para por
algunos por algún sector de la población
como un acto de un posible acto de
guerra hacia Rusia y el tercer punto es
también clave hay que recordar que
el las fuerzas armadas de Alemania por
muchos años han
un poco abastecidas entonces
poder enviar en estos momentos
tanques pesados tanques de guerra le dio
por dos traería un descontento dentro de
las fuerzas armadas por la falta de
abastecimiento Entonces estos tres
aspectos tienen que están siendo
considerados para un posible
para darle luz verde y dejar que
Alemania quite el veto para esta
reexportación o para en un dado caso
también poder donar tanques de guerra a
Ucrania claro de recordemos también que
Alemania tiene ya un nuevo ministro de
defensa podría cambiar de alguna manera
este nuevo ministro de defensa la
posición del canciller o laptoise porque
como bien lo decías él dijo y que pues
va a seguir evidentemente su país
Alemania apoyando a Ucrania militarmente
apoyándolo en esta guerra contra Rusia
pero no metiéndose directo en este
conflicto para evitar como bien lo
decías está descalada de tensión no está
de la guerra y que vaya más allá de la
frontera ucraniana
Sí
todos los cojos están puestos en el
nuevo ministro de defensa Boris
pistorios
él es un hombre Leal al cancillers Pero
él también en mi opinión creo que sabe
ver que hay un cambio en la opinión
pública y también hay un cambio en las
circunstancias hemos visto en esta
semana los ataques
a los civiles a la infraestructura
Ucrania en otra medida y creo que esto
requiere un punto de inflexión hemos
visto también que que Alemania ha dentro
del gobierno de shorts ha tenido un
cambio de su posición al principio
estaban en contra de enviar cualquier
tipo de tanques de guerra y ahora ya se
comprometieron a enviar tanques de
guerra Armada que son más para un cierto
uso
defensivo pero en marzo ya estarán
siendo enviados estos tanques entonces
en ahorita en los círculos políticos se
está hablando de la posibilidad de un
cambio entonces todo indica que que es
posible Este cambio al menos dentro de
la coalición del gobierno de shock los
verdes y los liberales están de acuerdo
en que se envíen
tanques de panzados o para empezar
quitar este veto entonces creo que el
nuevo ministro tiene buenas cartas para
hacerlo y si bien el esto un acto de
equilibrio ser Leal al conciliario pero
también se lea a otro a los aliados
aliados europeos y yo creo que aquí
también Alemania ha dicho en varias
ocasiones De hecho hace un par de
semanas o lapsos en un dijo que Alemania
quiere ser un garante de la seguridad de
Europa y para ser garante hay que
liderar no solo hay que esperar a que
otros envíen Entonces esto es al final
El dilema Cómo puede Alemania seguir
apoyando a Ucrania pero al mismo tiempo
no no Solo esperar a que otros envíen
este tipo de armamento pesado primero
sino también ser un líder en este
aspecto claro y también digamos el
canciller ola cholos hablando de los
aliados estaría Esperando algún tipo de
reacción ante Estados Unidos yendo Más
allá de la fronteras europeas Porque
también se dice que
dijo estaría dispuesto a enviar estos
tanques leopard Alemania siempre y
cuando también Estados Unidos mande los
tanques abrams pero Estados Unidos
también el Secretario de Defensa dijo
que pues no era tan fácil enviarlos
porque nada sirve enviarlos si no pueden
pues manejarlo correctamente no pueden
hacer las reparaciones necesarias porque
tienen pues una un sistema complicado no
de de funcionamiento estos tanques
Entonces cómo qué lectura le podemos dar
a todo esto
bueno la posición de cancillería yo
siempre ha sido
que la que se tome una posición en
conjunto con los aliados y los socios no
solo en Europa sino también con Estados
Unidos esta Alianza transatlántica y
también tomando en cuenta la posición de
la otan yo aquí veo un cambio Ya vimos
en hace dos días Este que Gran Bretaña
Se comprometió a enviar catorce tanques
de guerra pesados los Challenger esto ya
es una señal política de que Ucrania
necesita ayuda y que es necesario
hacerlo Yo creo que
todos este tipo de decisiones se van a
tomar en Rammstein en la reunión que
estaba llevándose a cabo el viernes
entre tus diferentes ministros de
defensa de la otan y creo que este será
un tema básico siempre se le ha
criticado de parte de Estados Unidos a
Europa que parte de la seguridad
Europa disfruta en estos momentos o o en
el pasado ha obtenido es por toda la
seguridad que ha otorgado Estados Unidos
hay que recordar que muchos países
dentro de Europa no logran ni siquiera
hasta el dos por ciento del producto
interno bruto en su defensa en la
defensa entonces Creo que este sería un
buen momento para que los europeos no
esperen la acción de Estados Unidos sino
que inicien y tengan la iniciativa en
apoyar a Ucrania donde la guerra es en
Europa es este al final una guerra que
hace que que sea importante que las
democracias estén juntas en este momento
Y si bien si está esperando quien lidere
creo que en este momento siendo la
guerra en Europa los europeos Alemania
puede liderar al mismo tiempo que
coordinar porque esta el tiempo que cada
tiempo
cuando al tiempo Ucrania tiene que
recibir la ayuda ahorita
vamos a ver que está guerra será
prolongada Y eso puede causar más
muertes y puede también traer efectos
masivos en Europa como lo estábamos
conversando al principio Diana también
está la presión digámoslo así de los
aliados europeos sobre todo de Polonia
no que está como que en el centro de
toda esta disputa el Primer Ministro
polaco Mateos moravia yqui como estamos
comentando también al principio dijo que
va a ser todo lo necesario para apoyar a
Ucrania con el envío de estos tanques y
dice que está autorización de Alemania
sería algo secundario hablemos de de
esta autorización no que sería como todo
el meollo de de este asunto Qué tipo de
autorización tiene que dar Alemania para
que Polonia realmente lo tenga que
enviar Y por qué Polonia dijo que es
algo secundario que ellos lo pueden
hacer digamos
Bueno yo creo que
no estamos viendo como hay una presión
en específico de Polonia pero también de
otros países del Báltico como Estonia
lituania letonia para a lo para lograr
que Alemania permita que se pueda
exportar estos tanques esta cláusula no
se puede cambiar porque está
fija de que Alemania necesita dar esta
luz verde creo que la parte de este esta
discusión es una forma de llevar de de
presionar Porque si bien en un en un
primer paso Alemania puede dar luz verde
para que se reexporten los tanques de
guerra en un segundo paso puede podría
Alemania donar por esos parte de sus
leopardos de su propio Arsenal entonces
este segundo paso es lo veo en un corto
plazo difícil de llevar a cabo pero el
primer paso sí Y esta sería una forma de
demostrar
de que Alemania no sea un obstáculo para
que en estos momentos de Ucrania reciba
la ayuda que sea necesaria también hay
que comentar que
Estonia acaba de dar uno de los avisos
más importantes de que estará dando más
de un por ciento de su vip en ayuda
militar solo a Ucrania Entonces estamos
viendo como la presión se está eh
diferentes países están presionando
Alemania a no obstaculizar
la ayuda de los grupardos gracias Diana
por su tiempo por estar con nosotros en
directo América de France 24
gracias